[Musique]
la duchesse de bourbon fille légitime et
de louis xiv acheté il ya deux siècles
et demi un terrain vague jouxtant le
fameux pré aux clercs et il fit édifier
un palais le palais bourbon celui-là
même monsieur le député au bout
siégeraient demain et à côté duquel
comme le montrent des plans de turgot le
marquis de lassay se fit construire un
hôtel plus petit devenu depuis celui du
président de vote rassemble
édifié par gabriel voici le palais
bourbon vue de la scène tandis que rue
de l'université la grande entrée est une
galerie en 2000 une reliant deux
pavillon carré de trois étages
l'hôtel du marquis de la cei fut conçue
comme une réplique donnant lui aussi sur
la scène et sur la rue de l'université
où il apparaissait au fond d'une cour
impose en cinquante ans plus tard les
deux bâtiments devenus propriété de
monsieur le prince de condé lequel il
procède à d'importantes transformations
que les parisiens venaient admirer
depuis les berges du cours de la reine
rive droite
à la révolution voici le devant du
ci-devant palais bourbon où siègera
depuis l'an iii l'inutile conseil des
cinq sens qui disparut au 18 brumaire
soulan pire pouvait transforme le côté
scène pour faire pendant à la madeleine
un escalier monumental avec un péristyle
à 12 colom et tandis que des haut relief
chante la gloire de napoléon celui ci
regrette de n'être plus officier
d'artillerie pour pointer dit il c'est
canon contre cette façade qu'il déteste
d'ailleurs il a tort
[Musique]
nouvelles transformations encore à
l'intérieur à la place de la salle du
conseil des cinq sens le compte de la
bourdonnais ministre de charles dispose
en novembre 1829 la première pierre de
l'actuelle salle des séances
l'assemblée va rire à 10 fois encore
d'appellation pourtant contrôlé mais
plus guère d'aspects du moins à
l'extérieur l'entrée principale quand
ils mentent à être celle de la rue de
l'université
sous la monarchie de juillet les députés
siègent de part et d'autre d'une allée
centrale les séances houleuses commence
sous louis-philippe sous la deuxième
république le peuple envahi le palais
bourbon le 15 mai 48
[Musique]
mais sous le second empire le corps
législatif délibère dans le calme et
l'austérité semble-t-il
et ce sera à l'extérieur du palais que
gambetta proclamera la république
troisième du nom en 1870 mais la chambre
des députés a aussi ses heures non
politique voici une soirée dans le grand
salon des fêtes donné le lendemain du
jour où devant l'attentât à la bombe de
vaillants le président charles dupuis
s'écriait la séance continue
tel est donc faite de mondanités
officielle et de travaux politique très
brièvement résumé l'avis de cette maison
monsieur le député où vous retrouverez
dans cette salle des séances l'ombre des
grands hommes ici poincaré
demain nouvel élu vous ferez
connaissance avec les installations
ultramodernes de vote et vous croirez
d'abord que tout ici est lumineux
mais tout ce qui brille n'est pas or
voici venir d'autres symboles
les charb de députés pour soutenir vos
convictions républicaines sous les yeux
de la loi car vous légiférez c'est
pourquoi nous vous avons élu et vous
n'oublierez pas monsieur l'élu du peuple
que si les régimes sont passés les
français ont toujours espérer que les
travaux de votre assemblée donnerait
enfin raison à la topographie puisqu'en
principe vous travaillez si près si près
de la concorde
[Musique]
mais entrons maintenant dans le palais
auguste pour une promenade imaginé pour
nous par daniel brèque
dans la salle des séances la tribune des
arts à terre l'histoire ces tablettes à
la main note vos parents de la renommée
a embouché la trompette de votre gloire
derrière vous le président regard de
l'assemblée il distingue la droite de la
gauche par rapport à sa tribune la même
cloche servant à diriger toutes les
pensées vagabondent ans par trop voici
la salle des pas perdus 20 mètres sur 11
plus loin la salle des quatre colonnes
où vous trouverez le nom de vos
prédécesseurs mans pour la france
ailleurs encore ce haut relief en bronze
monsieur de mirabeau le citoyen marquis
aux états généraux en juin 89
[Musique]
et vous vous travaillerez dans la
bibliothèque ou en levant les yeux vous
admirerez couronnant le tout se
déroulant deux coupoles en coupole les
admirables peinture d'eugène delacroix
la splendeur de ses lieux sera propice à
votre recueillement et vous en
profiterez monsieur le député pour nous
donner des lois censées peut être même
compréhensible
à l'hôtel de lassay le président de
l'assemblée s'assoira devant un bureau
celui ci en habit chaque fois qu'il sent
mira président et vos débats le voici
qui se lèvent passé dont monsieur le
président 503 de vos collègues vous
attendent la porte s'ouvre sur l'avenir
de la france tandis que vous passez pour
aller en séance sous des lustres de
cristal scintillant de la grande galerie
[Musique]
désormais vous n'appartenez plus à vous
même monsieur vous devenez vous les
députés ce corps de la grande histoire
rappelle le législateur nous vous avons
élu messieurs en notre âme et conscience
et vous souhaitons respectueusement du
bon travail
[Musique]